investing in well-being straightening
strengthens the economy the idea of the
economy of well-being is that we should
put people and their well-being at the
center of decision-making in its
conclusions the council invited the
Commission and member states to follow
the basic principles of the economy of
well-being in policymaking and other
actions we have also discussed how to
strengthen and anti-discrimination
measures in the EU it is crucial that we
safeguard ego treatment for all in the
EU as society change and as the world of
work with evils lifelong learning
becomes more and more important as a way
of matching skills and needs discussed
and adopted council conclusions today on
issues that will continue to require our
attention and action in the years to
come how do we better match skills and
labor market needs in a world that
continues to change how can the European
pillar of social rights be further
implemented at a new and national level
so as to the level what minister packin
on and his colleagues calls an economy
of well-being an economy in which
economic and social progress go hand in
hand and are mutually reinforcing